there was another interesting moment you
know one of the people that I
interviewed uh this was yesterday as
well yesterday morning was Marjorie
Taylor green congresswoman from Georgia
now if you listen to the mainstream
narrative on her she's a white
nationalist and something about a Jewish
space laser and she doesn't like black
people or something and she's an
insurrectionist I actually found her
quite lovely she was very able to
explain what she believes we we talked
about a little bit of everything but
later in the day she was doing a hearing
and they were talking about uh what
happened in Tennessee and she's having a
back and forth uh with uh what's his
name Jason Moskowitz is it Jason
Jeff Moskowitz represent I'm sorry
representative Jared Moskowitz about
shootings and uh sort of how she evolved
on some of this stuff
any question I'll
Yeti who Greece that murder in schools
is not murdered will you yield oh I'll
yield yes please yeah I was when I was
in 11th grade and Joe Biden made our
schools gun-free school zones one of the
students in my school brought three guns
to school and our entire school went on
lockdown because he was the only person
with a gun there was no good guy with a
gun to protect us kids at school you
want to know why the shooter is dead in
Nashville the trans shooter you want to
know why because a good guy with a gun
killed that woman she identified as a
man she was mentally ill probably taking
hormones and she went in and murdered
children and adults in this Christian
school in Nashville so if you want to
have a good talk about schools and
protecting children we need to talk
about protecting our children the same
way we protect our President we protect
our celebrities we protect reclaiming
thank you Mr chair
you got it it's just the truth these
people exist and are able to scream
about taking away our guns while they
are protected by guns remember that
video we showed you about a month ago as
Gavin Newsom was walking the streets of
California talking about how the GOP is
in a suicide pact with the NRA because
of guns and he's surrounded by like
eight armed security guards because
that's the only way he can go out in the
state of California I know you guys get
it
foreign
[Music]